support the david pakman show and pick
yourself up a Janus SmartWatch designed
by Kronos Blade I love mine it can do
anything my phone can do you can take
photos with the dual camera a
videoconference download any Android app
use it as a fitness tool it can make
calls like a phone it has GPS it has one
of the biggest screens out there 1.6
inches
check it out using the link right
underneath this video so I woke up this
morning I had planned my morning and we
really planned the entire production day
around watching as much of the Robert
Muller testimony before Congress as
possible so that we could talk about it
today which I'm going to do right now
rather than on tomorrow's show and I
thought as I got on my computer at 8:25
a.m. this morning to pull up the stream
I should see if Donald Trump has been
tweeting because he's been panicking for
days yesterday we covered Donald Trump
saying that Robert Muller shouldn't even
be allowed to testify I should look at
whether Donald Trump has sent any tweets
I pull up Donald Trump's Twitter account
and he sent 10 tweets in the hours and
even minutes before Robert Muller's
testimony starting last night winding up
even more this morning this is a guy
who's panicked this is the president
it's important not to lose our sense of
scope this is the president devolving
into a childish nincompoop and I use the
term nincompoop by its dictionary
definition not as an ad hominem because
of congressional testimony by a former
special prosecutor and you know what
unfortunately in a sense fortunately for
Trump Mueller's testimony at least the
first several hours that have taken
place as of right now have not been
particularly damaging to Donald Trump
but we'll get to that let's look at
Donald Trump's tweets to begin with
starting last night quote so Robert
Muller has now asked for his longtime
never Trump or lawyer to sit beside him
and help with answers what's this all
about his lawyer represented the
basement server guy who got off free in
the crooked Hillary case this should not
be allowed rigged witch-hunt continuing
so democrats and others can illegal
fabricate a crime try pinning it on a
very innocent president and when he
fights back against this illegal and
treasonous attack on our country they
call it obstruction wrong why didn't rob
eart molar investigate the investigators
continuing quote it was never agreed
that Robert Muller could use one of his
many Democrat nevertrump or lawyers to
sit next to him and help him with his
answers this was specifically not agreed
to and I would never have agreed to it
of course it's not up to trump the
greatest witch hunt in US history by far
why didn't robert muller and his band of
18 angry democrats spent any time
investigating crooked Hillary Clinton
lying in leaked in James Comey Lisa
Paige and her psycho lover Peter s Andy
McCabe the beautiful or family fusion
GPS and how many more and many more
including himself and Andrew W this is
the president tweeting ok continuing so
why didn't the hide why didn't the
highly conflicted robert muller
investigate how and why crooked Hillary
Clinton deleted and acid-washed 33,000
emails immediately after getting a
subpoena from the United States Congress
she must have great lawyers no collusion
no obstruction Keep America great
continuing this is still Trump on
Twitter this morning it has been
reported that Robert molar is saying
that he did not apply an interview for
the job of FBI director and get turned
down the day before he was wrongfully
appointed special counsel good luck even
following this stuff hope he doesn't say
that under oath in that we have numerous
witnesses to the interview including the
Vice President of the United States
Donald Trump melting down in a
completely unprecedented way which says
a lot when we're talking about Donald
Trump who has melted down on Twitter
many times before but then in the end
and again maybe something will change in
the later hours of the testimony that's
still going on as we're filming today
the first many hours have not been
particularly damaging to Trump
although there were many damaging things
said or confirmed by robert muller and
muller is looking confused and not
really with it I have to say what I was
looking for going into the hearings
today included do Republicans go after
molar in personally despite him having
credentials that should appeal to the
right I mean we're talking about
military a lifelong Republican a life of
public service do they try to assail his
character and they did to some degree
what new information comes out and hint
the answer is none robert muller stating
in his opening statement listen we've
charged 30 defendants we've had seven
convictions or guilty pleas but
basically the report is my statement and
i will be limiting myself to what is in
the report pointing out importantly his
report nor his investigation addressed
collusion they looked at conspiracy but
collusion is not something on which they
reached a conclusion because he didn't
look at that period and that's an
important thing but molar by and large
looking confused unable to hear
questions cut persistently I mean
regularly and I don't think it's a
strategy of trying to kill time by
asking for almost every question to be
repeated molar asking people about who
even some of the players in this thing
were at one point I believe it was David
Cicilline from Rhode Island asked about
Corey Lewandowski a very specific
question and molar said can you just
remind me who Corey Lewandowski even is
so I don't believe that this was
strategy by molar he genuinely seemed to
be having trouble hearing having trouble
recalling people's names and their role
in the investigation to some degree I
guess to be expected because you're
dealing with hundreds and even thousands
of names here but regularly saying I'm
going to pass on that one that's outside
my purview clamming up but what's in the
report is what I believe even sometimes
saying he can't comment on something
being reminded by a member of Congress
that it's in the report and then saying
oh well in that case my comment is
what is in the report I don't know that
this was particularly successful for
Democrats beyond one very specific
series of questions towards the
beginning where Muller answering with
his very short
yes knows it's in the report it's out of
my purview did confirm the obstructive
nature of Donald Trump's actions during
the investigation including that the
motivation to the extent that the
investigation came to a conclusion on
this that Trump's motivation for his
actions in attempting to obstruct were
specifically meant to interfere with the
investigation
so overall we'll i'll go right back to
watching this after we're done filming
today and we'll have sort of a broader
analysis tomorrow of the impact it is
not seeming to me that this testimony is
going to be a game changer and to that
extent for everybody who was waiting for
something explosive to come out of it as
I said from the beginning all we could
really expect from these hearings well
optimistically was the proactive
confirmation and publicizing of what was
already in the report Mulder made clear
the report is my statement I will not go
beyond it there were lots of damaging
things to Donald Trump confirmed but in
a way that again was sort of muddled
stumbling around in the dark seemingly
confused by robert muller also we
learned that louie gohmert congressman
louie gohmert is completely off the
rails and really shouldn't be a member
of congress if you saw bits of that
testimony you'll probably know what i
mean we will have sort of a full summary
tomorrow but i don't know that it is
necessarily going to move the needle and
that is what gets me to this next topic
which is really about most importance at
this point in time